hey David if Trump runs third party do
you think he can win any states this is
a really interesting question because
I think the answer is is maybe yes I
mean listen if you if you look at a
variety of different states and you pull
Republicans and you say how many of you
would vote for Trump
if he ran again for the most part Trump
has more than 50 percent Republican
support I think in every state I may be
wrong but there may be some state where
Trump wouldn't have 50 Republican
support the math gets more complicated
when you realize that a trump Republican
nomination in 24
and a trump third-party run in 2024
would differently affect Republicans
uh Independents and Democrats so let's
take it one by one if Trump is the
Republican nominee I think that that
will motivate more Democrats to vote
against him than if Trump runs as an
independent because Democrats will see
Trump as an independent as less of a
threat than Trump as a republican okay
if Trump uh is the
Republican nominee I think that
Independence will go more away from
Donald Trump where if his Trump is where
is Trump if Trump is an independent or
third party uh candidate it might
actually attract some Independence who
otherwise would have said no no no this
is not for me I'm going to vote for the
Democrat and then for republicans and
this is where it gets really hard to
predict
if Trump is the Republican nominee in
2024 I think he has almost all
Republican support every poll is
indicative of that but if Trump runs as
an independent about 60 percent of
Republicans in a poll a couple of months
ago said they would follow Trump to a
third party or or an independent status
I don't know that I believe them
I genuinely am unsure that they would
actually follow through with that so all
of these are complicated scenarios now
could Trump as a third party candidate
win some states yeah I think it's
possible I think it's possible that he
would but the real question is what does
it do in terms of getting to 270 and to
me it seems abundantly clear that the
math of a trump third party run points
one way in one way only which is a
massive Democratic Victory uh in
particular if Trump because remember
scenario one is that you've got a
Democratic candidate which who wins
the normal blue States and then the
Republican nominee and third party Trump
split the red States okay that's that's
one scenario but even without winning a
single state Donald Trump as a third
party candidate could absolutely destroy
the Republican party because if you
think of all those states where Trump
won but by half a point or Trump won by
one point or by three points or even
four
if Trump can pick up even 10 15 support
from Republicans in some of those States
they split the vote and you end up with
a situation like a Democrat having you
know 48 but having a plurality and the
other 52 percent being divided by Trump
and the Republican nominee so personally
I uh my my view as stated earlier this
week is if Trump runs against Biden in
24 and trumps the Republican nominee I
think it's very bad for Joe Biden and I
laid it out in detail earlier this week
if Biden says I'm only going to be what
doing one term
vote Kamala and Kamala is handed the
nomination I think that's very bad for
Kamala Harris I think Trump likely does
very well in that scenario so in that
sense I want Trump to not be involved at
all but
Trump as a third party candidate a
viable one who could get again 10 12 15
of the vote in some of these key States
um it gives the election to the
Democratic candidate and I've seen no
incredible mathematical explanation of
why that is not the right assessment if
you have one I want to hear from you
is there any scenario where Trump
getting 12 percent nationally as a third
party candidate doesn't obviously become
uh just a windfall for the Democratic
candidate let me know I want to hear
from you
during the pandemic and even at this
point I try to avoid physically visiting
a doctor's office unless I really have
to and that's why I love our sponsor
steady MD Primary Care you take a quiz
you get matched with a licensed primary
care physician who's a good fit for you
you have a one hour virtual appointment
and you start a meaningful relationship
with your new doctor after that your
doctor is available to you anytime by
text phone and video chat and unlike
other services this isn't some random
doctor on call each doctor at steady MD
has a limited number of patients so they
can give you the personal attention you
deserve they can help you with anything
your primary care doctor normally would
healthy diet managing conditions weight
loss sleep depression anxiety you don't
need insurance it's just 99 a month with
absolutely no other fees or co-pays for
visits take the free quiz and see which
doctor is a perfect fit for you go to
steadymd.com Pacman there's no risk no
long-term commitment the link is right
underneath this video